I'm so curious I'm not sure if you guys
have ever done anything on this scale
with this kind of action and everything
that went on with this so for both of
you what actually surprised you about
making a show like this or a limited
series like this
um what surprised me it's
the amount of people that are involved
in
not even
any TV series a lot of people involved
but in The Witcher world the amount of
people that are involved it's a big
world to be a part of
and I I've the attention to detail
throughout there's no skipping Corners
with this it is it's the real deal and
it's
um you're working with the best of the
best and it it was just a dream it was
just a complete dream and I think you're
aware when you step onto a show like The
Witcher how how big it is but I don't
think any of us really understood the
world that surrounds the Witcher with
the books and the games and and the TV
show it's a very uh passionate and
loving fan base and I think that was a
that was a real eye-opener for all of us
wasn't it stepping onto something of
this scale it was it was great I'm
curious obviously um when you were
looking at the scripts and you're seeing
what you're going to be doing what was
the day that you had circled on the
calendar as like oh my God I cannot wait
to film this
fight scene with Michelle yeah when you
get the script mate and you you look
ahead and you see that you've got a
fight with Michelle yo I mean that's
that's the one you Circle and look
forward to most I think it was it was
watching a watching a legend at work
even it wasn't even that I was in a
scene with Michelle it was just I got to
be on set watching Michelle yo fight
that was right
we were in that
I was actually going to ask you about
Michelle and getting to work with her
because she's a legend I love her she's
amazing nothing but positive things are
going to come out of my mouth
um what surprised you about working with
her maybe that you weren't you know what
I mean because she's such an icon of uh
anyway I'm just curious she was she just
says like
I think when you work with Legends you
can go in like and then immediately
you're just like oh it's Michelle like
she's just so normal and lovely and give
so giving to the whole process and a
great leader for us all to follow I also
think for many of us this was the first
kind of thing on this scale we had had
done but whereas Michelle's kind of been
there and done it all you know and so
she kind of took on the role as kind of
like the The Mummy or the Auntie of the
group
so giving and and so kind of calm with
us and it was it was a real privilege uh
I'm sure you didn't take anything from
set because no one would steal anything
but hypothetically
um did you borrow anything with every
intention of bringing it back I do have
a Gwen in my bedroom
um Nick Jeffries sorted me out
um with my own Gwen which is awesome
um and I'd be upset if I did have to say
bye to Gwen so yes it helped my grieving
process on wrapping on the show that I
still see her every day and I have my
butcher's Cleavers in my living room
yeah
um when you actually got cast how much
had you seen The Witcher before and how
much did you feel like okay I gotta
watch it all I gotta play the game
telling friends and family listen don't
bother me because I need to play the
game all day today
I mean I played the game when I was
younger my brother is is a big kind of
uh computer player and and he he used to
buy me stuff for Christmas and I I got
The Witcher one Christmas so I was kind
of I was I knew all about it from from
that but uh you kind of I was fresh I
was fresh into the world of The Witcher
which was awesome but terrifying at the
same time because it was a slow trickle
because the scripts come so confidential
when you're auditioning that it took a
while for me to realize that Witcher was
what I was auditioning for because it's
all code names and different
um that sort of thing so once I clicked
on I then was like oh wow so once I sent
the tape off I then got to enjoy the
series and uh with a pizza in hand and
be like wow I can't believe I'm entering
this world
um on that note I gotta stop I'm just
gonna say congrats and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating thank you
thank you so much